briefing and now I will make a statement in
my capacity. I thank the general
understood how
famous our American colleagues are for
this kind of thing, but I was sure that
this time, given the attention
that was attracted as ugly
behavior, everything would be different,
but I was wrong about
the country that is
called itself
in  in general, I did it. I saw stupidity. Well, I
showed what
her
oath of assurance about protecting Freedom of
speech, access to information, and so on is really
worth.  listen,
over the past few days, we have repeatedly
turned to them, therefore, the question is
nevertheless the result. As you can see, deplorable
and this is despite the fact that we were given
assurances that visas are on the way just about a
minute they will be
issued all this lies this is an outright
lie
and it does not paint the country hosting itself
on its territory headquarters
Dear colleagues, we again, as in the years of the
Cold War,
approached a dangerous line, the situation may be even more
dangerous, the situation is aggravated by the
loss of faith in multilateralism when the
financial and economic aggression of the West
destroys
globalization when Washington's
allies refuse  diplomacy
is required to sort things out on the battlefield;
all this is within the walls; it was created to
prevent the horrors of war